hello everyone and welcome to today's
live
broadcast the pharmacogenomics behind
the investigational treatments
of covid19 and its high risk underlying
conditions
i'm christy jewell of labrutz and i'll
be your moderator for today's event
today's educational web seminar is
brought to you by lab roots
and sponsored by admira health
for more information on our sponsor
please visit admirahealth.com
now let's get started i would like to
remind everyone that today's event
is interactive and we encourage you to
participate
by submitting as many questions as you
want at any time you want during the
presentation
to do so simply type them into the ask a
question box
and click send we will answer as many of
your questions as we have time for
at the end of the presentation if you
have trouble seeing or hearing the
presentation
click on the support tab found at the
top right of your presentation window
or you can use that ask a question box
to let us know you're experiencing a
problem today's presentation is
educational
and thus offers continuing education
credits
please click on the continuing education
credits tab located at the top right of
your presentation window
and follow the process to obtain your
credit
i would now like to introduce today's
presenter dr becky winslow
senior clinical pharmacogenomics
specialist medical affairs department
at admira health for a complete
biography on dr winslow
please visit the biography tab at the
top of your screen
welcome dr winslow you may now begin
your presentation
hello and thank you for joining me today
for our webinar on the pharmacogenomics
behind
the investigational treatments of
covenant 19
and has high risk underlying conditions
my name is dr becky winslow
i'm the senior clinical pharmacogenomics
specialist
in the medical affairs department edit
mirror health
at the conclusion of this webinar i hope
that you are able to describe
how pharmacogenomics directed medication
therapy management
before exposure to covid19 has the
potential
to reduce the chances of patients with
chronic disease
experiencing severe or fatal coded 19
infection outcomes and also to be able
to describe
how pharmacogenomics directed medication
management
has the potential to improve the
efficacy
and decrease the toxicity for
medications used to treat
codeine 19 and it's sequelae
let's get started by looking at
the prevalence and the epidemiology for
coded 19
in the united states
as of april the 21st 2020
there have been over 800
000 total cases of coded 19th
out of that number there have been
almost
45 000 total deaths
coded 19 has affected patients in all 50
states
and its territories
for hospitalized patients in the u.s
according to the cdc
the highest rates of coveted infection
have occurred
in adults that are aged greater than 65
years old
as we would expect the most common
pre-existing conditions in these
patients
are diabetes chronic lung disease
cardiovascular disease and those
patients that are immunocompromised
so let's take a look at the pre-existing
conditions
as well as the medications used to treat
those pre-existing conditions and the
pharmacogenomics behind them
as i mentioned previously diabetes
which includes hyperglycemia and insulin
resistance
cardiovascular disease such as
hypertension or congestive heart failure
chronic lung disease such as asthma
or copd
needless to say precisely managing these
conditions
best prepares a patient for exposure to
coded 19
and should the patient become infected
with codeine 19
they may experience better outcomes the
healthier they
are
so let's look at the pharmacogenomic
gene drug pairs that are included
on it mirror health's pgx1 plus test
for cardiovascular disease we have a
cardiology section
medications that are frequently used to
treat the cardiovascular diseases that
we
that we've suggested are included in
this section
we also have an endocrinology section
the medications in this section of the
test
are used to treat diabetes
and lastly we have pulmonary a pulmonary
section
the medications in this section of our
test
include the drugs and genes that are
used to treat
asthma copd and cystic fibrosis
again precisely managing these
medications
using the patient's pharmacogenomics
data
may help mitigate coded 19 outputs
so let's take a minute to look at the
immunocompromising conditions
that can predispose a patient
to coded 19 infections should they be
exposed to copin 19.
these conditions include cancer
infectious diseases such as hiv
tuberculosis and hepatitis
and also autoimmune diseases such as
lupus rheumatoid arthritis and psoriasis
in addition to these conditions
predisposing
a patient to an increased risk of
covid19 infection
some of the medications that are
consumed by these patients
can actually increase their compromise
and make them less able to fight off
coded 19.
so let's look at the pharmacogenomic
gene drug pairs
that are included on the ptx ones plus
test by mirror health
for cancer we have oncology medications
as you can see here we have some of the
most commonly used cancer medications
including cyst platinum fluorouracil
tacrolimus we also have
infectious disease sections in this
section we have the genes and drugs
that are used to treat the infectious
diseases i mentioned previously
such as hiv and hepatitis
lastly we have a rheumatology section
on the pgx one plus test as i mentioned
earlier
some patients may actually take
medications
that can reduce their immunity
and set them up for code 19.
the medications in this category are
included
here in the rheumatology section and
they include methotrexate
humira embrell and remicade
again by precisely managing
a patient's medication using their
pharmacogenomic data
can help set the person up
to be resistant to coded 19 infection
and should the patient become infected
with code in 19.
they will be healthier so they can fight
the disease
we're now going to discuss the
pathophysiology
of code 19 we're going to look at how
the
human body responds through the immune
system
and we're also going to take a look at
medications
and their pharmacogenetics they're being
considered
for use in the treatment of covid19
in either the pathophysiology
the human response or the acute clinical
course
that results from coded 19 infections
the image that i'm showing you here
is a picture of the inside
of an audio light within the lungs
you can see the alveolus and the hostile
division
coping 19 is similar to other viruses
in that it binds to a specific receptor
on the host cell membrane so that it may
enter
the host cell to replicate in the case
of code19
it binds to the h2 receptor
if you see in this picture that
interaction is enhanced by tmpr
ss2 keep that in mind because we're
going to look at that a little bit
closer
on the next slide
the next step in the pathophysiology of
covin-19
is the viral membrane fusion and
endocytosis
as i mentioned earlier covid19 is
similar to other viruses
in that it then uncoats
it releases its rna into the host cell
it replicates itself
it restructures itself
and then it exits the cell through
exocytosis
there are several medications that are
under investigation
that target the steps in the coded 19
pathophysiology
you can see them now on the screen at
the place of their action
within the covid19 pathophysiology
pathway we're now going to look at some
of these medications
up close and in more detail
we're first going to look at the
investigational
anti-coded 19 medications
and i want to point out here that the
reason that we call them
investigational anti-coded 19
medications
is that many of these medications are
actually
approved for other indications
for use in the u.s by the fda
however in the treatment of coded 19
there are no fda approved
medications
the medications that we are
investigating are simply being
repurposed
for the use in codin 19.
so let's look at tmtr ss2
inhibitors if you recall from our
previous slides on the pathophysiology
of code in 19
tmprss2 facilitate the binding
of the sars virus ovid19
to the ac2 receptor one of the
medications
that is most studied as a tmp-rss2
inhibitor
is chemostat mesolate this medication
is not available in the us but again
it is being considered in clinical
trials
secondly we have the medications
hydroxychloroquine and chloroquine
you've probably heard a lot about these
medications in the media
they mitigate coded19 pathophysiology
by inhibiting the viral entry and
inhibiting
endocytosis of the viral contents
into the cell
these medications are also thought to
have an immunomodulary effect
within the host
lastly we have arbidal
arbidal is a viral membrane
fusion inhibitor
it works to inhibit
the ace ii and
s-protein binding
to prevent vowel entry
the net effect of these medications
is that they decrease coded 19
virility
this group of medications are also
investigational anti-cova 19 medications
you may recognize these medications for
their use
in other viruses in the us
the first group are the vowel protease
inhibitors
which include lepinovir retinovir
and ethanovir
the second group are the rna-dependent
rna
polymerase inhibitors such as ribovirin
remdezavir again
some of these medications are approved
for use in the us
some are within clinical trials being
studied
and some are awaiting fda approvals
their net effect is to decrease
coded 19 virility so that it cannot
replicate
this last group of investigational
anti-code in 19 medications
work a bit differently and some of them
are controversial
for use as anti-code 19 medications
the first group are the angiotensin
receptor blockers including losartan
and valsartan these medications bind to
the h2 receptor
and they block coded 19
from binding to the h2 receptor
angiotensin converting enzyme inhibitors
decrease
the conversion of angiotensin 1 to
angiotensin 2
and therefore they reduce
vasoconstriction
and its sequelae which contribute to the
poor
outcomes for coded 19 patients
one school of thought about these
medications is that in fact
they may be negative or they may cause
harm
in the treatment of codeine 19.
the school of thought is that
angiotensin receptor blockers
and ace inhibitors may actually
cause up regulation
of the ace receptors
and therefore provide
more binding sites for the coded 19
virus
to enter into the host cell and
replicate
the last group of investigational
anti-coded 19 medications
are the anti-androgens such as
spironolactone
and plutomites these medications
actually end up acting like
cnpr ss2 inhibitors because they disrupt
the androgen pathway
that is how they mitigate coding 19
pathophysiology
so let's take a look at the
pharmacogenetic drug dream pairs
for the miscellaneous therapeutic
classes of medication
that are being investigated and trialed
as antivirals for the treatment of
codeine 19.
some of these medications are included
on it mirror health pgx one plus test
that is those medications that have the
highest level
of clinical validity and clinical
utility are included in our tests
as i mentioned earlier many of these
drugs
are still investigational and some are
not approved by the fda yet
now that we've looked at the
pathophysiology
for coding 19 now we're going to look at
how the host's immune response
works after infection
so once the coded 19 virus
has infiltrated the alveoli
vowel replication triggers a
hyperinflammatory
response once this response
is triggered there's an influx of
activated neutrophils
and inflammatory monocytes and
macrophages
th1 and th17 are induced
and specific antibodies are produced
we're now going to look at medications
that immunomodulate the host
immune response again
these medications may or may not have
been approved
in the u.s for conditions
in the u.s they are investigational
for use in coding 19.
the first immunomodulator that we're
going to look at
is interleukin 1 receptor receptor
inhibitor
and a kenra
the second is interleukin-6 receptor
inhibitors
next we have laurenmab which is a
chemokine receptor antibody
and lastly we have the janus kinase one
and two inhibitors
the net effect of each one of these
classes
is that they mitigate the human immune
response
to covid19 in the cytokine
storm that results
in covid19 and is thought to be the
critical factor
to poor outcomes encoded 19.
the last groups of immunomodulators
include corticosteroids such as
budesonide
ludicasone and triumph synalone
another group of immunomodulators
are the granulocyte macrophage colony
stimulators
we also have complement inhibitors
and last but not least drugs such as
tacrolimus
which are t helper cell dependent b cell
response
inhibitors
these medications all are expected
to help with covenant 19 by mitigating
the human immune response
and the cytokine storm that can result
so what are the pharmacogenetics related
to these immuno modulators
you'll see those here in this chart
having the pharmacogenetic data for
these medications
makes it possible to personalize
immunomodulator therapy for your
patients
to mitigate the covid19
outcomes
as i mentioned before we're now going to
look
at the acute clinical
course the patient experiences
post-coded 19 infection
the three most common conditions
reported for patients with coveted 19
infection who are hospitalized
are acute respiratory distress syndrome
coagulopathies and sepsis or septic
shock
needless to say one or more of these
conditions
increases the patient's risk for poor
outcomes anyway
that we can precisely manage these
conditions
we may be able to decrease poor outcomes
and improve the positive outcomes for
coding 19.
this first group of medications that
we're going to look at are considered
adjunctive care in the treatment
of acute respiratory distress syndrome
because patients with acute respiratory
distress syndrome
are most often intubated anesthesia
inducers
are needed to place the patients
on ventilators anesthesia inducers
include fentanyl hexanocholine
medazolam ketamine and propofol
additionally patients with acute
respiratory distress syndrome postcode
infection
experience a fluid overload
in their lungs in fact
ards has often been termed
drowning on dry land because of the
fluid overload
in the lungs to mitigate
the fluid overload diuretics
are prescribed to reduce
the amount of fluid
hydroxychlorothiazide
furosemide and spironolactone are some
of the medications
that are used as diuretics and acute
respiratory distress syndrome
and lastly we have the inhaled
vasodilating agent these medications
are indicated for primary pulmonary
hypertension
in the u.s however
they are being investigated for use
in treating acute respiratory distress
syndrome
secondary decoded 19.
i mentioned earlier that in addition to
acute respiratory distress syndrome
patients with coded 19 can also
experience coagulopathy and sepsis
the adjustive care used in these
conditions include thrombolytics
for coagulopathies and antiseptics
such as azithromycin
here we have the pharmacogenetic gene
drug pairs
associated with the medications that are
used
as adjunctive care in the treatment of
patients
with acute respiratory distress syndrome
coagulopathies
and sepsis postcoded 19 infection
having your patients pharmacogenomic
data at hand
so that these medications can be
precisely managed
will lead to better covenanting outcomes
so now that we have talked about covid19
infection we've talked about the host
immune response
we've talked about the acute clinical
course
let's talk about the mental health
consequences
of coded19 needless to say
patients who had mental health
conditions
prior to the coded 19 epidemic
may be experiencing flares in their
condition
and patients who may have never
experienced
mental health conditions maybe
experiencing mental health issues
for the first time
in particular patients who survive
coded 19 who have been in the icu for
conditions such as
acute respiratory distress syndrome
sepsis
and coagulopathies often have a
post icu syndrome
that includes the mental health
conditions of ptsd
anxiety depression and pain
these patients having survived covid19
deserve to be able to take the correct
medication
the correct time the first time
and in addition to patients who survive
coded 19
there are frontline healthcare workers
and the general public
who also could benefit
from the pharmacogenomic data to
precisely prescribe
the psychiatric medications
shown here are drugs and genes that are
included
on a merrill health pgx one plus test
this list is not a full list
in summary pharmacogenomics medication
therapy management
before coveted 19 infections
to properly and precisely
mitigate pre-existing conditions
to prepare patients with chronic
conditions
for coveted 19 exposure covid19
infection
and covid19 survival
in addition pharmacogenomics directed
medication therapy management
after a patient is infected with covid19
can positively mitigate
the pathophysiology of covid19 the host
immune response
coven 19 the acute clinical
course that results
from coding 19
and the mental health issues
that may arise or be intensified by
coaching 19.
thank you for joining us today i have
added references
at the end of this presentation for your
use
and digging deeper into this material
this concludes my presentation and i'd
now like to open the floor
for questions and comments
thank you dr winslow for your
informative presentation
we will now start the live q a portion
of our webinar
now to our audience if you have a
question you would like to ask
please do so now just click on that ask
a question box located in the far left
of your screen
and we will answer as many of your
questions as we have time for
okay let's get started wow we have so
many questions already coming in
dr winslow let's begin with this one
many hospitals are reporting that venus
thromboembolisms
are contributing to coven 19's high
mortality rate
can you elaborate on the medications
being used to prevent
and treat the coagulopathies and their
pharmacogenomics
sure that's a great question let's take
a look
um the data that has come
out of china the netherlands france and
the u.s
is reporting that there is a high
correlation between vte
and mortality rate for covid 19.
currently the ist-8
is recommending that all patients that
are hospitalized
for coven 19 who do not have any
contraindications
to prophylaxis
be prescribed the standard prophylaxis
that any patient that enters the
hospital
would be given if they were deemed
critically ill and at risk
for vte so those medications
include i'm going to move down
in my slide deck
so the medications that are
currently recommended by isth
are the low molecular weight heparins
and fonduperinu
now in addition to those two medications
if a patient progresses to an active
vte isth is recommending
body weight dosing low molecular weight
heparin
or heparin
and for those medications let's see
let's
look for their pharmacogenomics
okay so um these are the
pharmacogenomics that are associated
with heparin and the low molecular
weight heparins
on slide 36
then on slide 37 i have
the pharmacogenomics that are associated
with
the oral anticoagulants which are the
medications that are being recommended
should the prescriber decide to
transition the patients out of the
hospital and
for discharge so warfarin
and river roxabin are included on our
pgx oneplus test
thank you dr winslow okay now
as we've learned from deservier was
granted emergency use approval by the
fda last week for treating coping 19.
will edmera health be adding rem
desevier and its associated
pharmacogenes
to its pgx1 plus tests
that's another great question edmera
chooses which medications to add
to their test and which genes based on
fda guidelines so
medications that are included on the fda
biomarker table
and also medications that have
pharmacogenomic
indications in their fda approved drug
labels
and we also include medications that
have
cpa guidelines so
only when rem deserver is fda approved
and its pharmacogenomic biomarkers
are identified by the fda or cpap when
we add them charges
thank you now is chloroquine which is
included in the pgx1 reporting
the same medication chemically as
hydroxychloroquine
they are not the exact same chemical but
they
work very similarly
dr winslow if an 80 year old has already
had
a pharmacogenomics test well before cova
19
what if any communication should be sent
to that person
regarding covid19
sure i actually feel like that's an
excellent opportunity to reach out to
that patient
and do a medication check the best
the most optimal place for
pharmacogenomics
is preemptive so
reaching out to that patient and doing a
medication review
to make sure that the patient hasn't
discontinued medications or started new
medications
um just to make sure that those
medications are
optimized so that that patient can be
at their best their best condition that
they can achieve
so i think it's an excellent opportunity
to
to make that that check in and review
the medications
um with their pre-existing
pharmacogenomics results
thank you dr winslow now we have time
for a few more questions but i do want
to let our audience
know that any questions we are unable to
answer
live today and additionally those
questions that come in during the
on-demand period they will be addressed
via the email address you provided at
the time of registration
okay let's squeeze in a few more
questions here
dr winslow are there medications such as
chloroquine
that should not be used in persons with
g6pd
deficiency
absolutely and
that's part of the concern that we're
looking at
for example with hydroxychloroquine and
chloroquine that
approved were approved for emergency use
by the fda
they are g6pd is mentioned in
fda drug labeling for those two
medications as well as other medications
even
outside of coding 19.
dr winslow is there enough time to get
the results back or is this on patients
who
have already had the test
well the test results take about seven
to ten
business days after we receive the
sample
now the best case scenario
is for patients especially those that
have
underlying chronic health conditions
like the ones i mentioned in the
presentation
the best case scenario is for them to
have had
a pharmacogenomics test before they
experience a crisis or end up in the
hospital
being treated for covid19 or any other
type acute situation so depending
on the length of say in the hospital yes
the results could be returned
uh before the patient's discharged but
you know it's also important to consider
that what's going to happen to the
patient
and what medications might be used to
manage that patient
post hospitalization so currently
we don't have enough long-term data
to show what the
long-term consequences for coding 19 are
going to be
so the test is just as valuable
the results are just as valuable for
that patient post
hospital state also
dr winslow do diabetic patients also
have increased
risk of infection and or the disease
severity
absolutely absolutely as a matter of
fact
the number one chronic condition that
predisposes patients according to the
cdc
for covid19 infection is obesity and
obesity is quite commonly
related to type 2 diabetes
so absolutely and as a
as the diabetes is actually the
second highest
underlying condition for patients that
have poor outcomes
now we see too many useful drugs but how
do we decide which ones are the
best ones and with the lowest side
effects
sure um it would be great
to say that a pharmacogenomics test
was a perfect um map
for how to prescribe but in reality
pharmacogenomics is a tool in the
precision medicine toolbox
so in
addition to clinical factors that go
into choosing medications for a patient
pharmacogenomics can
can help with that process to
help choose those medications there'll
be more efficacious for the patient
and have less toxicity
thank you and we have time for a few
more questions how much burden do you
see due to different ethnicity of the
patients
based on the data that has been reported
thus far
from hospitalized patients with
coca-19 whites
are proportionately having
more cases of infection and being
hospitalized
next would be african americans and then
hispanics
um it is important though to point out
that these are hospitalized patients
um the numbers that we have from the cdc
so
what's actually happening in the
community for patients that either a
didn't seek health care or they thought
health care
and they weren't uh considered to
need hospitalization um the numbers
may be different when you look at
the inclusion of
patients that are not hospitalized with
patients that
are hospitalized
thank you now dr we have found that the
breakdown of the medications
and specific gene to be very helpful my
question is
how do you see the outlook on the
significance of pharmacogenomic testing
implementation changing post coded
my hope is that we because covent 19
is so personal uh we don't know
all of the um
we don't know everything need to know
about covid19
and we need medications to treat it
and prevent it so my hope is that
this will this scenario has taught us
the need to look for the pharmacogenomic
basis
how to treat and how to prevent diseases
thank you dr wenzel and we'll wrap with
this final
question how can someone be able to
receive
a pharmacogenomics test if they're
interested
oh absolutely um so for anyone that's
interested
in receiving a pharmacogenomics test for
mcmarrow help
or interested if you're interested in
ordering pharmacogenomics tests
i have here on slide 33
i have pulled up our address
our telephone number and i have our
website
i'm in if you go to the website you'll
find that we
now have um online ordering for your
pharmacogenomics test
so patients can go to our website now
and they can request
a test and secondly providers can now go
to
our website and they can order tests for
patients
and have those shipped to the patient so
we've made it we've tried to make this
situation
very easy for people so that they can
obtain a test
thank you dr winslow and do you have any
final comments for our audience
i'd just like to thank you guys for
hosting me and
i'd like to encourage anyone that has
any questions
any further questions to email me
i'll be happy to answer those questions
for you and
glad to be here thanks for joining
and thank you dr winslow and before we
go i would also like to thank our
audience
for joining us and for their interesting
questions we had so many questions we
are unable to answer live
so just as a reminder those questions
and again those questions that are
submitted
during the on-demand period they will be
addressed
by dr winslow via the contact
information you provided
at the time of registration i'd like to
once again
thank dr becky winslow for her time
today in her important research
we'd also like to thank labyrinth and
our sponsor admira health
for underwriting today's educational
webcast today's webcast
can be viewed on demand and labberts
will alert you via email
when it's available for replay we
encourage you to share that email with
your colleagues
who may have missed today's live event
that's all for now
we thank you for joining us stay healthy
and have a great day
you